il
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour la
vallée des géants règlement de comptes à
ok corral victoire en tb vingt mille
lieues sous les mers j'arrête tout de
suite là cette énumération il me
faudrait au moins 10 minutes pour citer
tous les films qui vous ont permis de
voir sur grand écran notre invité
d'aujourd'hui c'est en effet vous l'avez
déjà reconnu kirk douglas qui va passer
50 minutes avec nous que douglas vous
arrivez les états unis vous êtes arrivé
il y a deux jours alors je vais quand
même vous dire rapidement ce qui se
passe actuellement en europe d'abord
c'est attentats en espagne qui s'est
produit en fin de matinée six gardes
civils ont été tués dans la province de
biscaye à l'hôpital laennec depuis cette
nuit monsieur joseph fontanet et sur une
table d'opération
après l'agression d'entités dont il a
été victime le diagnostic des médecins
est encore extrêmement réservés le
président de la république ce matin à
baume-les-dames baume les dames c'est
dont le doubs un département français
le chef de l'état a parlé de la
formation professionnelle de l'emploi et
surtout de la mobilité de l'emploi enfin
à la veille du congrès de ceux du
syndicat de la magistrature
daniel grandclément passera dominique
coujard au crible
kirk douglas de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique quelles sont les grandes
préoccupations d'aujourd'hui du moment
j'arrive à paris pau fait les
présentations
les césars 7 samedi et ça c'est un
plaisir pour moi parce que je suis
toujours très content d'être à paris
malgré que j'ai fait le premier film
français à paris il y a
mais plus que 25 ans et depuis cette
époque je n'ai jamais fait un emprunt
français je crois que c'était quel film
c'est un acte d'amour avec anatole pas
mais je voudrais poser une question à en
revenant est petit pourquoi genève
je n'ai pas faire autre film français
peut-être que j'ai fait quelque chose
dans la dois je sais pas vous allez
tourner quand même deux films avec un
metteur en scène philippe français avec
rené clément si je le tronc non non mais
pas tourner donc dans les moindres il
n'est pas fait paris brûle-t-il de temps
et
dans les doigts croisés non on oui oui
j'ai joué j'ai joué onze jours oui bien
sûr vous avez raison cette espèce béni
oui oui oui ça c'est vrai je l'aï oublié
j'ai très bien de régler les dossiers
travailler un jour mais ça c'est pas la
face et pas longtemps
non mais dans l'es11 jour de travail non
les doigts croisés avec marlène jobert
de rené clément aussi là ça a duré plus
d'un jour quand même maillot mais oui
avec mamy gervais j'ai fait un film à
londres
il est retourné en angleterre oui mais
avec un metteur en scène réalisateur
français maintenant non non c'est pas un
règlement qui a fait savoir
mais c'était parce que c'est moche et
ses marques et son second livre c'est
marqué dans ce grand livre avec tous les
tubes de 1,5
vous avez raison - geste on ne sait pas
on parle de cinéma dans quelques minutes
si vous voulez bien parce que quand même
attendre et à sa question absolument pas
tant qu'on sait mais elle y va il va
vous la posez tout de suite en tous les
cas kirk douglas
si je résume rapidement votre carrière
cela fait soixante quatre films plus ou
moins pourquoi et un oscar à hollywood
pour votre interprétation dans le film
qui était consacré à la vie de vincent
van gogh
voilà votre carrière je vous propose
quand même de la découvrir un peu plus
en profondeur avec france roche qui va
nous faire votre portrait né le 9
décembre 1916 à amsterdam états de new
york et du théâtre à lula pour collègues
une certaine betty qui est devenu
vedette sous le nom de lauren bacall
fait la guerre dans la marine ont retour
et remarquée dans un show de broadway
c'est hollywood tout de suite où il
devient vedette avec des films comme l'
empire du crime le champion le gouffre
aux chimères detective story
il a joué toute sorte de héros de
spartacus haddock hallyday d'un droit
vikings à ulysse en passant par van gogh
qui lui a valu un oscar a fondé il ya 26
ans brina production et à travers cette
société à redonner une chance aux
écrivains de la liste noire comme dalton
trumbo sa femme anne qu'il a rencontré
au festival de cannes il ya 25 ans
administre brina et tient sa maison il
possède une des plus fameuses
collections de peinture moderne de là
twc est ses fils l'ont suivi sur ce
chemin et l'un d'eux michael douglas est
un producteur à succès celui de syndrome
chinois comme il dit lui même il a du
travail pour toujours puisque ses fils
sans producteur ed pas d'erreur pas de
missions moi je vais faire une
rectification
quand même parce que je suis fautif j'ai
mal lu ce qu'ils avaient dans le livre
s'est dit clément et non par rené
clément qui a fait ce film effectivement
des peines a dit clément vous avez vos
invités arrivent et angles il est engagé
vous avez vous invité côté de vous je
crois que les téléspectateurs les ont
déjà tous reconnu capucine et puis henri
verneuil alors un cinéma sérieusement il
a des questions à vous poser des
propositions à vous faire et charles
aznavour qui est avec vous pourquoi avez
vous invité henri verneuil on sait mais
capucine et charles aznavour
vous savez les tombes des trains america
possible aux revenants et moitié moitié
moitié en amérique moitié en france je
crois que c'est moi qui voulait devenir
vedette enfonce un film d'henri verneuil
avec capucine comme partenaire et une
chanson de charles aznavour et vote soit
pas un frein à bord lui même bien sûr
l'asvel pas si vous savez me joue très
bien
c'est bien et arrive de temps en temps